all along this part of the border there
are sites like this even though it's
been clear for three days that the
border with Europe will not be opened
they still come just in case just we
need a piece we need something to
survive we need them alive we need our
kids to grow up to good life to good
future the man doesn't want to be
identified it's often the way they fear
reprisals from the regime they fled
there from Syria we follow them around
the corner like everyone here they are
confused not entirely sure where to go
through a tunnel a villager ahead is
offering them another lift closer to the
border they're still full of hope that
crossing is possible and so on another
truck they move on not far away a group
have given up they arrived a few days
ago and now realise that crossing is
unlikely I'll go back home the boy says
and back to school and that's the thing
many of them here are migrants who had
actually begun to settle in Turkey but
dropped everything when they were told
the border was open thinking Europe
would be better down the road two men
from Iran they told us they'd managed to
cross to Greece yesterday but then they
claimed they were hit by Greek border
guards and had their phones taken they
were sent back to Turkey at the official
border crossing a team from the Turkish
government had arrived among them a
senior advisor to Turkish president
during the government here is very angry
they feel the EU is not sharing their
burden of migrants you brought them here
and they reject any suggestion that they
have created this crisis sake brought
these people here no key government and
the greece government they are playing
with us such as a football game they are
passing us to right heft 22 year old
Omid Mohammed II is from Afghanistan so
we came from there to here to go to
Europe to get a better life to guaran
to sit and leave such a human beings but
we know now we are here I don't know
what to do we are not having the chance
to go back or to foreign flying above
all this on the Greek side of the border
the European Union's leadership they
took an aerial tour of the EU frontier
at a new moment of crisis for Greece and
for them on the ground they took no
questions and placed the blame for this
with Turkey the migrants and refugees
cannot be used as instruments as pawns
in a geopolitical game they are the true
victims of these types of policies and
this is an approach that cannot be
deemed acceptable the problem is that no
one feels they can take this burden they
can't agree to share it mark stone sky
news on the Greece Turkey border